most people in silicon valley you know
they have a hammer and everything is
nail and that hammer is tools and
they're going to build a tool for
everything
and they're the mindset is pure software
ai is going to do everything humans are
irrelevant uh
humans aren't even going to exist in the
[Music]
future
francis pedraza thank you so much for
joining me on 20 minute leaders
thanks for having me michael it's it's a
pleasure to have you we actually met for
the first time
seven years ago you came to speak to our
summer class at mit launch x it was
about
everest which i know that it's you know
a long time back for you now
with all the different things that
you've done since then but but thank you
for being such a source of inspiration
for us back then it was really fantastic
thanks for remembering and for reaching
out of course of course i'm i'm really
excited to have you here
francis i'm not going to do justice to
to go over over the incredible bio
because you've actually had
a pretty incredible upbringing a pretty
global one but but
all sorts of diverse activities i'd love
to just spend the first few minutes
going a little bit over your journey who
are you what are your passions and
that i think that that'll that'll be a
really good leeway into the things
you're doing today and and some source
of inspiration
for for young entrepreneurs like myself
my mother grew up in iran and came to
the united states before the revolution
but when the revolution happened
her world changed and she
had finished her undergrad but she
dropped out of graduate school and
became an entrepreneur
and worked really really hard to um to
succeed
and and did and then when she had me
she she sold her company and um
you know focused on raising me my father
grew up around the world um his father
worked for
procter and gamble and other american
companies so he spent some time growing
up in
places like japan and the philippines
and venezuela
and um and so you know i think i got the
immigrant uh value set which is a lot of
uh hustle and determination and hard
work and a sense of
i think patriotism for the united states
that you know this is a place where
um dreams can happen and you can you're
you're in a free country
you have property rights rule of law
and you can build something here and uh
and express your potential
and um and so that was my upbringing and
my life changed
uh you know i was pretty frustrated in
both public and
private schools for a variety of reasons
until i discovered
this incredible internet entrepreneur
who was teaching
hundreds of students on skype zoom did
not exist back then
but he happened to be a local and he was
teaching them a five-year course
in the great books of western
civilization and uh you know the first
book we studied was homer's iliad
and then the next was the odyssey and
then we went on to you know read
many of the ancient greeks and the
romans and then the medieval scholastics
renaissance and enlightenment you know
and moderns in a number of subjects and
reading the original sources
writing about them debating them
discussing them and so i developed this
like you know
um passion for the humanities
and uh i um people ask me how did you go
from that
to starting a company um and um
i uh my first company was called everest
it was
you remember it it was an iphone app to
help people achieve personal goals
and um and i thought that you know steve
jobs had his metaphor
that technology could be a bicycle for
the human mind you know that would it
would almost be like an ironman suit
like
we could express our potential with
these tools uh at
a pace that we'd never been able to
before you could move
at the speed of thought and uh and then
we sort of live in this dystopian
reality where
uh you know that t-shirt that has like
you know the ape
and then a homo sapien standing tall and
then
humans behind a laptop and we look like
an ape again it's like we live in this
dystopian reality where it feels like
we're slaves to our devices instead of
you know uh the other you know the other
way around where these technologies are
empowering us
like why is that and so uh with everest
i was trying to build a social network
except around doing things instead of
around who you know
and you would have all your goals in the
app and um and i i thought that you know
we could live up to that da vinci and
dream have a new renaissance and have
people
uh pursue their their full potential and
have technology actually help
but the company failed the app failed uh
and it was a very humbling
sort of icarus experience where
i had to learn a number of lessons um
both about how to build a great product
how to build a great business
um and uh and and
but it also made me rethink some of the
fundamental some of the fundamentals
um and with invisible my current company
i've tried not to compromise on the uh
the
um the vision i think same vision uh
just different business model different
mission
and uh and i've been trying to apply the
learnings in a very very different uh
to solve a very very different problem
which is industrializing knowledge work
um so before we go into that a little
bit and understand about
you know that icarus like experience
because inevitably you know
almost all entrepreneurs are going to
fail multiple times until they get to
their success and i'd love to
to focus a little bit on this every
story i remember when you came to
to speak to us i remember how we all
looked at how we all looked at
this at this amazing part of that you're
building and you know the charisma and
the vision
and we all bought into it immediately we
knew this was going to be a major
success we loved it and you have to
understand francis that this is a bunch
of you know 16 17 year olds entrepreneur
wannabes
that they're getting so excited and are
buying into this
this product and and that i i need to
have this closure to understand what
what happened there and
how why why do you call this a nicholas
like experience and what what lessons
really do translate now
to your next venture
yeah um it was a beautiful product uh
you know apple featured it many times uh
i think the design community recognized
the work that our designers had done
um and um you know uh it was
before facebook had an iphone app you
remember when they were they facebook
thought
their corporate strategy for a few years
was we were going to be web web only
um until they realized that it was a
mistake you know uh it was the early
days of the app store
and um we had nearly half a million
people use it
um and their initial experience with
everest was kind of
this you know euphoric uh experience
we'd be like wow i could
i could put all my goals and dreams into
the app i want to go to italy i want to
look like daniel craig in a bathing suit
i want to
run a marathon i want to buy a house you
know all the things you just
fantasize almost that part was easy but
where the business failed is that three
four five six months later
people would stop making progress on
their goals you know we was
tr it was almost like instagram for your
goals you could post photos and videos
but also complete steps like a checklist
and make progress and the discipline
required
was too high so our business model ended
up looking like a gym
you know gyms don't make money when you
get fit gyms make money when you want to
get fit
they divorce monetization from retention
and that was a key principle that we'd
missed and uh
and you know we thought we were gonna be
have a business model look like facebook
but basically that business model is
selling dopamine like a drug
and uh like a digital cigarette and it's
it doesn't really require
effort or follow-through and so you know
oops
um uh beginner's mistake and that was
the icarus
uh moment so fast forward to today tell
me a little bit about
the insights of the industry in the
market even before we get to the actual
product because because you have some
really fascinating insights into
into where we're headed as a global
economy in the workforce
and and that's leading into what you're
working on today so i'd love to
really get into your mind and understand
the motivation behind what you're doing
and
particularly taking a little bit of a
leap forward into what's going to happen
in the next few decades
yeah i'll start by describing what
invisible is and then i'll
uh share some um
some predictions about the future um so
uh
we're you know every company has complex
and custom
processes um and they're very difficult
to automate even if you know about all
the latest automation tools
even if you're aware of robotic process
automation rpa tools or
workflow or no code automation tools
or you're aware of the relevant you know
software point solutions for the
particular function you're trying to
automate say it's sales or hiring or
marketing
um or an industry specific you know
workflow
you're trying to build um there are all
these tools
um you know there's an app for
everything why isn't everything perfect
yet and the answer is that when you try
to
automate your process you know any one
tool might help you automate five ten
fifteen percent of it
but you can't get the end to end
solution you need to run your business
tomorrow so what do you do you either do
the rest of it in-house manually or you
outsource it to a traditional
outsourcing company a business process
outsource or a bpo and bpos are like law
firms their incentive is to bill you as
many hours as possible
uh they're selling labor they don't have
an incentive to automate
on their side so invisible is combining
outsourcing and automation for the first
time
and we call it work sharing and our
technology
is a digital assembly line and
it has two layers the first is you know
we coordinate 280 workers
in 35 countries around the world who can
log into secure
virtual desktops and follow step-by-step
instructions to do the manual portions
of the work
and then the second layer is that you
know we break down these custom
processes into standard steps we think
of it like sequencing the corporate
process genome
and then we will automate those steps
over time and they become reusable
and our business model is a win-win as
we automate your process
uh your unit price goes down and our
margins go up so it's a win-win
we have an incentive to automate and you
see your prices drop
and our inspiration for all this was
from what henry ford did to
manufacturing in the early 20th century
every you know this is like pre-world
war one um i mean the whole story of
ford from like 1908 to
say 1960 is fascinating
but every year the quality of their
cars improved the price decreased
their revenue increased their margins
increased
and the amount that they paid their
workers increased
these things are in trade-off
relationships this
shouldn't happen and it only happens
through the economic miracle of
productivity gains which create
deflation
and deflation is good i call it the
deflationary gospel of capitalism better
faster cheaper better faster cheaper
and um i think that we're at a stage
where you know
the mission of the company with
invisible is industrializing knowledge
work
it's not automating knowledge work it's
industrializing it
and um and it it implies a more
nuanced view of automation and this is
what i'd like to communicate to your
audience
most people in silicon valley you know
they have a hammer and everything is
nail
and that hammer is tools and they're
going to build a tool for everything
and they're the mindset is pure software
ai is going to do everything humans are
irrelevant uh
humans aren't even gonna exist in the
future you know uh uh
uh ultron ultron is coming
you know and and i think this is
ridiculous and i think this is where
some of the liberal arts background
kicks in i think that you know um i
think in many times in our history we've
always thought we're at an exponential
curve
and it didn't end up happening uh things
happen quite differently you know um
if you read steinbeck's grapes of wrath
for example with the tractors coming and
automating agriculture
you know arguably the productivity gains
of that era were greater than the ones
we're experiencing today so
um the
this is what i think is likely to happen
i'll speak in very broad statistical
terms
there are you know just uh a pop quiz
for your audience
how many there are eight billion people
on the planet how many
how many people play video games
think about it pick to build your answer
in your head
it's three billion three to four billion
um
and uh and then how many people do
knowledge work
like make their livelihood on a computer
in some way
one billion
ah you you did your homework um exactly
um so there are one third to one quarter
as many uh knowledge workers as there
are video gamers now
um i'm going to attribute this to kathy
wood
at arkhanvest whose research i follow
closely but
basically video gaming is like a sort of
onboarding it's training for
the world's future knowledge workers and
if you think about what's going to
happen over the course of our lifetime
um you know do we think there are going
to be less than a billion knowledge
workers by the time we die or more than
a billion knowledge workers
and it just seems sort of obvious
i'll sort of ask the audience to grant
it to me as a as a
a premise or an axiom or an assumption i
could defend it but i just think it's so
sort of sort of obvious on its face that
there are going to be many many more
knowledge workers it doesn't make sense
that one out of every eight people work
on the internet
and seven out of every eight people work
in the physical world the digital world
is becoming
more and more part of everything that we
do
every industry is you know basically
becoming digitized so
um uh i think they're complementary
trends in robotics
you know but i think that basically in
our lifetime we're gonna have
you know up to four billion knowledge
workers maybe more
so so think about what that means in
terms of automation
if we were actually going to automate a
you know
even 50 percent of uh knowledge work
then we would go from a billion
knowledge workers to 500 million
knowledge workers in our lifetime and
500 million other people would have to
either be unemployed or find some
physical work to do
but i think the opposite is going to
occur i think what we're going to
experience is net
negative automation that even and
it doesn't mean we're not going to
automate we're going to automate a lot
but
i think that the key economic principle
is work can be created
faster than it can be destroyed and we
can destroy it pretty fast we can
industrialize it and automate
it and build all these tools pretty fast
but not as quickly as we can create it
and i think that
you know we're going to be in a sort of
dialectic where humans
are doing a thing and then computers
learn how to do that thing and then
humans do another thing
like a new trick uh that we then teach
the robots and then we're gonna keep
doing that dialectic for a lot longer
than people think
and uh and i think that um you wanna
design
your business model around that or at
least our business model has been
designed around that i think that
those are going to be the really
interesting opportunities not
necessarily the
you know selling pure pure sass pure
tools
francis why do you care so much about
this why i mean i saw how much he cared
about everest i saw that passion there
i'm seeing the passion now
i'm fee i'm feeling like as if i'm back
in that mit class in 2013
why do you care so much about this stuff
because the future doesn't necess i mean
almost by definition should be very
different than the past and and
presumably better um and i think one way
of thinking about it is
um you know if you saw a human being
that was seven feet tall you'd be like
wow that person's pretty tall
if you saw a human being that was eight
feet tall you'd be like are you in the
guinness book of world record you know
like you're you're like three standard
deviations tall
if you saw a human being that was 70
feet tall you'd call the military
it's an alien it's not a human anymore
it's like you know it's it's godzilla
it's a giant you know
there are just not 80 foot tall humans
but that's a metaphor for what is
possible with productivity gains
um and uh i think that uh you know
the mindset of silicon valley has been
the turing test
which is when can computers do all the
things that humans can do so we can't
tell
and i think that that's the wrong test
for a number of reasons i think a more
interesting test is the da vinci test
which is i think steve jobs original
intent
which is um you know in the 21st century
when will the average person
be more productive than the most
productive person
in the 15th century and
i think that you know in sort of a um
a one-on-one uh productivity test
uh da vinci with his piece of paper
would school
uh any millennial with their laptop and
iphone
and uh i think that that's the
embarrassing thing that
that we have all this all this
information and all these tools
and yet we're we're spending so much of
our time not being creative and not
being strategic
so um you know i think part of my
message is is deeply optimistic i like i
think i really believe in
in the the good that humans are capable
of
um but part of it is like a real um
reprimand in a sense like an exhortation
like we uh
you know harvard said that you know up
to 50
41 of the average knowledge workers time
is spent doing work that is repetitive
and i think we just did not get the
education and the opportunities that we
have
and we do not live in this like
incredible era in order to spend half of
our time doing
uh irrelevant you know we're doing doing
work that
isn't our isn't our highest contribution
right and we should have a certain
urgency
around um you know uh
solving problems building you know
creating things and i think that you you
know
uh peter thiel peter thiel has a i think
has the right philosophy
the right pessimism in his his basic
message
which is that like you know the iphone
is new our digital devices are new but
when you walk around our cities they
still feel like they're in the 20th
century
why is that you know um and i think that
that
uh there are you know kathy wood at
arkanvest talks about five technology
platforms
that are disrupting pretty much have the
potential to disrupt every aspect of our
society
you know i think the five are i'm gonna
hope i get this right you know fintech
and blockchain
uh robotics and um industrial automation
uh ai and automation which invisible's
in sort of software automation
uh enterprise tools um uh the genomic
revolution everything is happening with
crispr and gene editing
um and uh um everything that's happening
with uh autonomous vehicles i think
those are the five
um but uh the the reason i list them out
is that there's
there's you know this is such an
exciting time to be alive
um but we kind of have to have a fire
you know fire uh
about it you know um uh what's what's
the phrase light a fire under your ass
i can definitely feel the fire the
passion the urgency i'm getting so much
inspiration from the friends
before we end you have to tell me the
peter thiel story you told it to me
seven years ago back at mit launch with
everest and i need the short version now
for the audience because it'll be just
fascinating if you feel comfortable with
it of course
sure um so i
yeah he he uh is one of the people that
i look up to most still to this day
um i think he's an intellectual giant
and um
i was i just graduated from college and
i
i was starting everest and i had some
people interested in investing but
hadn't been able to make a breakthrough
there
and i met someone at an airport you know
uh
right when so pretty much uh i was
thinking about quitting and and i was
working on the the designs for the app
um and uh and somebody looked over my
shoulder and saw the designs and then i
asked me some questions and i answered
them and i told them about the idea and
they said would you like to raise money
and i said yes and they said from who i
said well
you know from who angels or vcs and i
said angels but specifically
um you know i peter thiel and he's like
well i actually happen to go to stanford
with peter and and i can i can introduce
you
and um i spent you know half an hour
tops talking to peter telling him about
it and he said well
send me some some materials and then i
just i like wrote a 50 page business
plan and i
uh i we everest created one of the first
web-based pitch decks and we released it
right around christmas
and didn't hear from him and then new
year's eve sure
i'm in for 50k and then everyone else
came in and you know we we raised 2.6
million and did this like journey for
three or four years
um and um uh
it was it was a lucky break um
and uh but something i think i'm always
gonna be grateful for and
and um i think there's still i think
it's a good it's a good example of some
magic
you know there are certain things like
generally you should
operate with the assumption that you
every single win you have to fully earn
it
um and uh you know but
as i look back over my career there have
been a number of people that have
given me favor and key moments and those
those were those were fortunate um
fortunate circumstances i'm very
grateful for them
and i think i think that's part of what
made silicon valley great
and i think it's still there
francis i i love it thank you and for
showing the story i think showing all
the other stories this was just
inspiring to to listen to again and
you know with the new insights and and i
can't wait to keep following your
journey and continue getting inspired so
thank you for everything that you're
doing
uh both to me the listeners but also
humanity win with all the different
products that you're building
before we leave i have to ask you the
most important question which is
three words that you would use to
describe yourself and i know that i'm
already keeping you late so thank you
for being generous with your time
yeah iconoclast classicist
and amateur uh iconoclast because uh
i tend to uh go against the norms
even when the norms are aesthetic i
think it has the you know contrarian is
a word we're familiar with
but iconoclasm has a sort of aesthetic
connotation that sometimes
being a contrarian kind of it's it's
actually unpopular
and weird and even can look ugly and
it's like what are you doing like
it's a weirdo uh and i think i you have
to embrace that
and then um classicist because i think
that which is ancient is often
futuristic the things that don't change
that you can learn the most from and i
think reading original sources in
general is good and particularly when it
comes to books i love reading books by
dead people
then amateur because um uh
in in the old word amatore you know you
have to have a certain
love for uh you know
trying new things and being like a child
and making making mistakes so i i have
many things that i do that i'm not an
expert in by any stretch imagination
like i love to paint
i love to um uh learn about subjects i i
i know very little about like i was
reading a bunch of white papers about
um autonomous vehicles i was totally out
of my depth but
hey you know i think that that that
helps make you well-rounded
and i think that for a couple hundred
years
everyone's been trying to become more
specialized but i think going back to
the renaissance idea of being the
polymath
uh and being versatile is a better way
to go but to do that you have to embrace
the identity of an amateur
francis thank you so so much this was
wonderful and stay safe and stay healthy
thank you again
cheers michael
hey